hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
now we're starting off with one called
lady ice that was made during the Asylum
jam a while back and it's been on edge
for awhile Michigan was full of work
lots of farms and cattle it needed men
and they were ride workers plenty during
the summer months but harder in the
winter [ __ ]
the storm doesn't just prey on the weak
all men are equal when the land freezes
over
I've seen men stronger than horses
freeze in minutes after getting caught
in the blizzard and there was the do
survive they live in fear of Lady ice
some folks say she's nothing more than a
tall table others say she might have
been something wants but now was nothing
more than whispers a ghost or the five
Estela children to keep them out of the
storm but when she comes knock those
folk won't be telling any stories Oh
know why cuz some sitting so stoked
defiers lot of candy it doesn't matter
what you do so long as you stay out the
dark stay out the dark stay out the door
no you're locked inside your cabin you
must survive until the storm passes
who else [ __ ] okay all right I'm down
holy [ __ ]
left-click to light your candles keep
them lit and stay in the light to stay
safe alright oh boy
what happens if I go into dork hold
shift oh my god my god damn candles yeah
hold you have to sprint away from danger
how do I know what scuse me oh my god
you can't light your candle until the
dark spell path I literally tap down the
game oh I had it you later can use
publicly four times before the storm is
over I don't know what that means
can I just go okay not bad I mean it
uses stock unity assets or stuff that's
publicly available but what they did
with it is actually quite impressive I
am very impressed all right let's try
this get holy hell Oh chip to sprint
away from danger I'm gonna sprint so far
away from Lady ice lady ice ain't gonna
get me lady ice could go suck a crack my
barrels
oh I see did I block up the door and
that's how she got in oh [ __ ] imma
[ __ ] in alright well look okay lady
ice I'm ready for you whatever you're
thinking just don't do it whatever
you're thinking don't throw it I saw
that I saw that I can't light until you
get away right okay all right okay
oh I see you okay I just got to stay
away oh god I can't see anything
Oh God okay I see you okay all right I'm
just gonna run cycles around you I hear
her oh hey wow what a good joke lady ice
you pretending that you're hi hello ice
okay I don't like that wait you're still
in here wait wait wait a minute wait
wait but that's not okay good okay well
here here she'll be coming round about
what you guys oh I didn't see where she
was
[Music]
I was here I was here I don't like that
I don't see where she I don't where she
is
Oh there hello hi okay huh lady ice
don't do it don't do it
did you forget lady ice [ __ ] off this
goddamn terrifying terrifying alright
lady ice okay lady ice let's all calm
down here
lady ice I got the fear burps come on
come at me lady ice lady is you in here
rarity where are you see you see you see
I don't like it there yard there you
okay no no no not today
you can knock my furniture all up whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh
[ __ ] okay all right this is fine
so what happened last time did I just
not run away from her correctly cuz it
seems like oh [ __ ] yeah you're still
here [ __ ]
butts sorry I got scared I legitimate II
got terrified oh boy
oh no no no whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I
don't know I don't know no no no no okay
she charged I think I think that's what
that was she charged two times nothing
about there being four times how am I
gonna survive four times if this
[ __ ] oh hey well that was close
it's totally fine just kids
you and me it's just going to flip that
over so I didn't run over it I'm gonna
hit oh [ __ ] light the light the [ __ ]
[ __ ] what's even the point who aren't
even the point
the point
but that was a lot closer than I thought
it'd be three times that's good to know
there's a five three big three big three
baby oh yeah yeah that is the worst
thing I've ever seen
no no no no no oh boy she seems to be
stuck in the middle she's like coming
towards me and then I don't know man I
don't know
oh it's whenever I run to the darkness
that's when she that's when she comes
for me oh I see okay all right
oh [ __ ] no no no oh that's not good
that's no no no no no no no no I don't
like the music
[Music]
No
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] gonna make it did I
survive
did I win I survived the storm they'll
be telling stories about you usually
they tell stories about you when you're
dead okay but I won that's all that
matters okay holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] okay
all right well goddamn that was
terrifying
anyway that was Lady ice what a start
what a start to this gear this video oh
my god all right
okay okay this next one's gonna be a
wonky one it's not exactly a horror game
as far as I know so the game in this is
quit the game to win
oops escaping all four won't work either
won't they
oh they won't they don't work there no
work sure there's the task manager but
that's cheating
that way you'll kill the process now
KITT the game what about that X button
at the top-right corner
oh you [ __ ] oh you [ __ ] nope
there must be a way to touch it X no I
think it just needs a friendly approach
be gentle okay okay let's try some real
[Laughter]
that's funny
[Music]
I don't think it's working I don't think
it's working either okay I think we
scared it off yeah I think so too
here take this it surely looks better oh
we didn't do nothing
wait I guess it's hiding somewhere maybe
it's a shy one try calling its name I'm
not an object Oh
all right try calling him by his name
I'm a sheath fine would you trees please
calling her by her name her ex ex ex ex
we got it I mean her now click on her
did we just win no crap I guess we
didn't okay here we go again we were so
close wait I have an idea when the
lights went off I think I saw something
oh god I hope I didn't say something
like a switch behind the title the
circuit breaker not the console anyway
try moving the title down under this
text box what do i what do I have to
move it over the text box I'm gonna move
it above it oh okay I see
alright so that was the main power
switch
what's that dangly thing I don't trust
that dangly thing huh there's a blinking
light now well progress I guess which is
good maybe I don't know looking uh no oh
I don't like that oh I don't like that
at all oh okay that's fine alright okay
what's going on wait don't touch that
button I just realized something
important killing the process is
quitting the game and that means I'll
cease to exist
how could you push that button how can
you kill the process after all the time
we spend together after all the jobs we
faced
how could you kill me okay fine I won't
interfere with your choices
oh I think this music is interfering
with my choice kill the process
well this sad music won't affect me
[ __ ] Lloyd get ready to get [ __ ] oh
did you really think it was that simple
nobody's gonna kill me you're not gonna
win this game I won't win this game god
damn it [ __ ] you [ __ ] you fine whatever
okay all right so that wasn't exactly a
scary game but I'll keep that in anyway
it was funny all right
let's play let's find two more okay
welcome to Dora is not not Dora is dead
this is made by the same guy that made
that Curran scary game I'm pretty sure
all right so Dora is either dead or not
dead and I don't know which is worse
find a way out okay clear and cut his
kid all right well then it's either made
by the same guy that made that or it's
made by the same guy that made 3:00 a.m.
at the Krusty Krab and then again maybe
those are all the same I don't honestly
don't know I found a way out I think
follow the trail of blood and I'm gonna
find where Dora ain't dead okay found it
again this looks like my way out find
the gate key easy breezy easy peasy
lemon squeeze me huh I've got chills to
have my spine who knows what lurks
behind the darkness I have a funny
feeling I know what lurked behind the
darkness and it took someone by the name
or or something that may or may not have
tried to kill Dora at some point what
the [ __ ] did you say on huh was that
Dora ah no who's this a gun a hammer
that'll come in handy
okay alright okay
oh-oh-oh-oh okay no use a hammer on the
blanks I'll use a hammer on the blades I
got a key good good good good dad but
smash that like button okay fine I don't
know if it's catching up to me but I got
a bad feeling about this okay
whoa-ohh-ohh get in okay we're fine oh
ha that was weird
what was that what did I see on the wall
uh okay I guess we're fine
did we make it did we what is that what
is that I think I have everything at oh
no it's the map that [ __ ] killed me now
your next Swiper
oh I'm the Swiper oh no they warned me
about swiping oh I knew it was gonna go
over me if I kept up my life of swiping
if I can get out of here alive I'll
never swipe again never Swiper good but
the key doesn't fit I should have known
the door was screwing with me oh the
real gate key must be around here
somewhere yeah I guess it shouldn't I
shouldn't have trusted the door that
said the key was inside Oh ha ha ha ha
all right we're fine okay never mind
we're not fine
all right Dora if you could just leave
me alone for two seconds all right I'm
gonna find wherever that corpse was I
guess maybe that's gonna have an answer
to me Oh what the [ __ ] well that's the
naughty children's room oh that's the
dead dude whatever room
no boy it's hilarious oh this game can
actually be scary I mean it's not that
scary admittedly what the [ __ ] is this
you're gonna I'm gonna tear your guts
out and devour I'm like a savage okay
all right
like a savage in a good way or like a
savage enough rar rar rar way oh [ __ ]
okay no I will not help you do your room
and dance oh my god that scared the piss
out of me
holy [ __ ] at least it seems like Dora
can't catch me
what is this is this way no this is a
different way Oh
[Music]
Oh leave me alone dad I just want to
swipe your key
is that so wrong
oh I'm not gonna be able to get out of
here Oh real Genki I hope well oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay I'm fine don't do it I hope
I can get around here nobody can get
around I think anyway why wouldn't I be
able okay fine
all right perfect the game designer
really smarted up the place and really
made this intuitive so I could get away
[Laughter]
what the back
[ __ ] you monkey [ __ ] you what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] monkey [ __ ] monkey okay all
right I think I'm good oh let me out
here huh highest cop rate okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
alright [ __ ] you okay
anyway Wow alright alright well that was
a spook and a half but now we've got
another game by the name of lonely
things and the artwork that I saw for
this game was just creepy as hell watch
the introduction yeah I'll watch it come
on what you got for me oh I gotta do
this I've been driving for so long that
I couldn't remember where I was going
yeah the roads all looked the same the
shadows out there never got any closer
it seemed like that night would never
end if I just kept going on all I wanted
was a place to sleep but had been hours
since I'd even seen a gas station I was
about to pass out at the wheel when
something began to take shape ahead a
building couldn't believe my luck it
looked like hotel something tells me
this may not be a hotel closed scapers
start to open the menu ah now this is
just a demo for a game that's gonna be a
full indie horror game at some point go
okay I'll go I'll go
it's real is this like an animal skin
rug why does this look like an animal
skin rug and what animal was this
freaking big cuz that don't look like no
normal carpet oh hi what the [ __ ] hi
hello holy [ __ ] you scared the piss out
of me hi ding ding dong hi oh my god
what the [ __ ] you're welcome right oh
you poor thing you look like you're
about ready to drop you want a room well
I already did the books for tonight I
suppose there isn't any place else for
you to go out there though go ahead up
to room 12 we can settle up in the
morning okay thank you just commenting
on your lovely rug beyond
[Laughter]
all right room 12 I don't know what room
12 would be but okay locked all right
locked okay all right in by process of
elimination
good great room oh that's that's weird
that's weird that's weird
weird huh okay everything's fine okay
what a [ __ ] what a [ __ ] oh oh I opened
it great I'll just lay my head to rest I
don't get any sheets or nothing that's
good hi hello there's someone in your ho
Oh what the [ __ ]
the bar is open grace wants some company
your car is gone now the bar is open now
where is the bar who is Grace
oh she's gone oh hi [ __ ] good [ __ ]
god stop that [ __ ] oh my god evening
looks like something's troubling you
your car was stolen
wow I guess that makes you stranded on
you don't have any hands
I'll keep an ear out for you it's Joe by
the way I've got a lot on my mind myself
I'm waiting on a special lady hey you
know grace I know left in your room huh
grace does that sometimes she's but
she's an honest woman maybe you could
try asking the manager about your car
although although what
my god
grace is that you grace no my special
lady's not here Joe wait weren't here
decisions she's really here by now in
the coroner table over there she looks
so beautiful in candlelight I had a
bottle of sleepy al for him I thought
she might even let me sit with her with
the manager that creep he took it from
me at least it must have been him he was
hanging around outside my room upstairs
earlier said he was fixing the lights
what a bunch of bull nothing ever gets
fixed around here
okay all right
lied nothing to light it with okay okay
Joe Oh Joe's not there anymore that's
strange
okay where is my car where's my car
where's my car
the only parking space where is my car
okay well I am perturbed
I am weirded out bing-bong hello can I
get some service can I get some goddamn
service here okay weird oh I can go in
here oh don't trust that at all okay all
right well that's weird
oh hi why oh hi okay all right I don't
like that like that you fixing the
lights where did I just go I didn't mean
to go in there okay it got quiet again
okay let's go let's go in the private
room
Oh grace
hello oh whoa oh don't get up do not get
up who the hell are you I don't know
anything about a stolen car talk to
Terrance he's the manager it's not my
job you'll probably find him somewhere
else so get out of here already
No hey again hey me again you know my I
read your letters do you lady all right
hey me again thanks for not telling dad
I've been writing not much it's changed
since I wrote last time I pretty much
clean rooms sit around listening to
music all day sometimes stuff happens
you get some real freaks around here
I found this plan or something under my
bed when I was cleaning the room one
today wasn't the grossest thing I found
in that drunk lady's room there's
probably the weirdest it moved never
seen a planet do that before I showed it
to Terrence anyone all quiet took it
from me and ran off from his office
hasn't come out since the old guy's
losing his mind ever since his wife
disappeared I'll tell you that another
time
I've been finding him talking to himself
wandering around the halls in the middle
of the night I wonder what he thinks I'm
doing it's been three months now since
that piece of [ __ ] dumped me by the side
of the road Terrence gave me a good deal
so I don't have much to pay for another
few weeks and I'll have enough to move
to the city I don't know what I'm gonna
do when I get there though I'm actually
starting to kind of like this place
don't ask me why I'll write again soon
hope you aren't still sick Jane so Jane
is it I told you to go away [ __ ]
people in this place well alright then
see Jane sorry you don't mind if I scoop
around alright well that what I thought
I saw something this games getting to me
which is weird considering it doesn't
seem like all that much on the surface
that's pretty good alright so Terrence
have you seen Terrence special ladies
not here alright whatever maybe one of
the other rooms are Oh the other rooms
are open oh [ __ ] oh oh oh this floor
looks like skin yeah well that's weird
listen man's voice mm-hmm is someone
there I've gotten myself stuck in here
somewhere
can't find my way out what what do you
mean in the intercom versus an air vent
it's hopeless I'm afraid I should just
accept reality things around here have
gotten worse lately so come back and
talk to me sometimes okay it takes my
mind off the noises
okay back already I'd love to talk but I
can't think of anything I'd say right
now maybe a little later oh okay all
right that is [ __ ] bizarre that's so
weird
that's so weird oh that's so weird it's
just stuck in the wall
okay sure let's go with okay
it's got to be another room that I can
go in if I can go on now and then other
ones must have opened up right from one
they said something about the lady in
room one you had a disgusting plan under
her bed no no what's with these doors
they're slanted switch Oh what oh okay
oh this thing this doesn't seem like an
office oh no I see the manager or
something weird happening what the [ __ ]
what is happening I got a key no I don't
I got sloppy out sleepy out not sloppy
al all righty then
I'm sure the manager whoa ah that's the
plan okay well it's just closed pretend
I never saw it
okay all right wow it's a ship on this
easy lovely all right I'm out of here
I'm going to get this sleepy out okay
I'm right here now
great okay let's get the bottle of
sleepy all over to this guy so he can
impress his fine lady grace my special
lady's not here she was here in the
corner table had a bottle of sleepy al
for it okay he took her from me all
right whatever what am I supposed to do
for it then do I put the sleepy owl here
there we go okay so I need something to
light that with too because I'm setting
the hill
No he was hanging at my room okay
all right whatever you say man whatever
you say if I leave and then come back
maybe or do I still need to find
something to light it with ah room nine
key okay I could pick up that key I just
wasn't able to pick it up right away
okay I got the room nine key that's good
room nine was next to my room I believe
okay so there's got to be something to
light something with over there
right or else that'd be stupid and
apparently I'm wrong which is an
entirely possible possibility lights out
baby okay I got a lighter what do I do
with the lighter anything oh hey cool
soap pickle soap can i oh it's moving
gross okay never mind then okay I'll
leave what the [ __ ] was that huh this is
like a leech or a slug why was it in a
medicine cabinet no whatever
I'll go light the candle and then I'll
go talk to the dude maybe he'll have
something else to say oh sure Boinky oh
okay
hi grace hey oh yeah yeah uh-huh yeah
how's it hanging how you doing grace
that's my favorite drink how did you
know I'm grace someone stole your car
huh well the good news is that means you
can have a drink with me maybe not here
though it's a little crowded we could go
up to my room here's the key I'm in room
1 it's right above us you haven't been
there before right no of course sorry
ignore me just meet me there in a little
while okay oh and if the manager asked
what you're doing don't mention me his
ideas how people should behave
right all right what do you think about
that you think I didn't hear that so you
think you're just gonna swoop in on my
special lady right in front of me huh
who the [ __ ] do you think you are well
i'ma go up to a room then that's who the
[ __ ] I think I am the guy who was given
a key to her room haha I'm sure this
isn't gonna go poorly for me I'm gonna
get laid and that's all there is to it
definitely not just a horrible vampire
hmm I'm gonna go with the horrible
vampire thing oh hello I'm sorry to slip
a note under your door like this but why
don't we talk anymore that night a few
weeks ago I told you I loved you and you
said you loved me too now you act like
you don't even remember I can't stand
seeing you in the bar talking to those
other men they're all just trying to
take advantage of you you know I'll keep
my distance like you asked but I don't
want you to think I've forgotten about
you grace I know you're in some kind of
trouble
is it Terrence he's been hanging around
outside your room maybe that's why
you've been so distant don't worry I'll
keep an eye out Joe all right I fell
down whoa oh you're a slug now you're a
slug you're a slug now you're uh you're
you're uh oh there's a slug here too
okay
oh oh oh you really felt oh you felt you
fell down oh okay I'll go in the hole in
the waterfall oh hi hello oh never mind
you know what bail bail bailing on that
Oh bail bail
Oh Christian Bale place you need to put
something he would want you to put well
look at that puzzle II need to put there
oh god I keep getting stuck on the
corners yeah hello hi oh no oh no oh no
oh oh oh okay you know what never mind
okay oh oh hi Joe how are you doing Joe
oh she's dead
why did she do that um I don't think she
did that it won't be long now it's
coming for me I've been like this my
whole I've never knew any other way to
be the truth is I just hate it all
there's no pain no trauma there's
nothing I'd rather be than a quiet drunk
nobody ever really wanted to understand
that at least here
people never bothered me till you Joe
you just won't leave me alone so I'm not
gonna pretend anymore the only way out
is down okay I got the plant then
you know what I don't know Joe I don't
know why she did that but something
tells me I probably give them does me I
got a place this plant over here all
right
yay yay for me oh boy thank you hi whoo
hey let's go in there oh oh hi oh hi
hello everybody my name is markiplier
how are you doing it okay whoa Wow yeah
I know you're all staring at this house
here is very lovely knock knock Oh
[ __ ] hi hello this isn't the place
for you oh this is the end of the demo
oops Q I'm scared of laughing cuz of
nervous alright so anyway thank you very
much for playing please keep an eye out
for the full game will be released later
in 2018 that was really something
it was really simplistic on his surface
but what it had was intrigue like it had
characters that were fascinating in very
short time you got to like understand
these characters and and it really gave
this concept of something like dreadful
in this place and that's hard to do when
everything's so simplistic so I really
applaud the creator this and I really
hope to see something cool come out of
this later because I would love to play
it that was honestly terrifying just cuz
it was so disconcerting and the people
were just weirdly made enough that they
were terrifying so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know he
thought these games down in the comments
below if you want to play any of them
like I always do there are links in the
description the pride links straight to
the games themselves so thank you so
much and as always I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]